[Music]
[Music]
hey guys welcome to tea time with
journey this is where I play tennis and
have a Q&A session with some my close
friends so I get to learn how to play
tennis better because I'm not very good
and catch up with my friends all at the
same time so it's great and today I have
a very special guest and it is her mom
[Music]
and actually Herman brought his own
racket to the dance
I'm that Pro my own racket that's a
little scary
I want you while we're playing - if I'm
like doing something wrong with my
position or something I mean it's not
like I know how to play I have no idea
how I play where I was he brought his
own racket I could have won why would I
not have won cuz you know all right
well we'll see on the court I guess
we'll see we'll see we'll see first one
to win three out of the five rounds wins
the whole game okay that's a lot of
pressure for me yeah so here we go good
luck good luck
heads or tails tails tail yeah
tails it is
ah you go here we go go first question
is how did we first meet ah
first we met online right yeah I think I
messaged you no point for me yeah let's
do something I was like yeah and with it
so mean stuff here's the videos I slid
into the DMS yep
all right ask me a question okay okay
ah what's your favorite thing about LA
productive come on yep Oh thirty yeah
awesome good for work like I can always
say busy oh I have to search I'm already
tired where's your favorite place in the
world
ah do like war vacation or something a
vacation to vacation
ah ah 15:30 yeah didn't up sink and play
at the same time I got a sink I'm cool
Cancun yeah I love it I like Cancun
better than Cabo when you wake up in the
morning what's the first a be open and
your phone Instagram
what about you twitter twitter i don't
love twitter but i open it uh-oh
come on out we messed up with such
ridiculous mess ups Oh 15:40 another
one's account the more I know about
tennis
the more I care I guess that goes with
everything
yep um when you don't know you have that
thing where like I don't know how to
play but you if you play you have no
excuse
yeah this is true did you know of me on
social media before I reached out ah
yeah oh yeah Lauren Kidman I wasn't part
of the whole binding because I was that
but uh you can't know the people that
are getting from there you know cuz it
was so big yeah what did you think of
minors at first honestly I thought it
was really hard to do videos like cuz
I'm so used to making videos like five
minutes or ten minutes so I thought it
was really hard to put like a joke or
something it's just six seconds oh
really so you respected oh yeah I
thought it was really love story in just
six seconds usually the youtubers hated
the idea of Viners
I don't know I don't care I think it was
really cool it's you get to push your
creativity to six seconds you know it's
like everything there and it gotta be
good and new concepts every day yeah I
look back at them now and I'm like oh
god I mean no one can look back and be
proud of their own videos um how did you
meet Lynnae we met ah women Oh in
control I mean II love we were on
vacation that's why you like Cancun yeah
I think good experience there we met
there we never stopped like meeting each
other so she went to Chile with me and I
will never stop since there are no keep
talking and serve oh okay sorry
oh god this is Tennyson questions
that's romantic
I know so did you teach her Spanish she
knew Spanish already she was she
she's teachers Spanish teacher yeah 40
Oh who's winning
you need one more no I did a double no I
got another another chance
if I miss now go boys get him on how
many girls did you date before you dated
Lynnae like date date or life girlfriend
girlfriend ah just the one really yeah I
mean when I was a kid that was 17 and I
date this girl but you know when you're
when you're a kid you don't know what
what really dating is that's true so
officially love 15 I don't want it like
that like a comedic kind of guy to one
girl and then to the next girl that's
sweet yeah do you guys do anniversaries
in Cancun ah wait we do what anniversary
no not really we actually don't have an
official anniversary yeah we cannot for
God today
guess we're dating and living together
so fast now we never actually remember I
mean yeah 1500
do you miss Chile ah I should but I
don't not yet really yeah cuz it's so
similar in so many ways
okay this is our cliche question you
know but if you wouldn't be doing this
why would you be doing if I wasn't doing
this I would be out out if I wasn't
doing this I'd be in the CIA good answer
oh wait so no I got to go again
Thank You ruff okay I Drive through the
back um how did you start youtubing why
like how'd that happen
uh what happened there what sounds right
yeah out go 30 all I was in my house I
was deciding between studying something
I really didn't want to study and or
just do something that I wanted to do
100 another time yeah and you two up
here there cuz it was super new so I
decided to go hunter person even though
YouTube wasn't like pain or anything you
couldn't call it a job what I decided to
give it a shot and I'm really grateful
for that
okay it ah 4030 what about you how do
you start in the industry I wanted to do
acting and I didn't have a reel and
every manager I met with told me I
needed a real so I was like what comes
first like the job or the reel so I
started making YouTube videos okay oh
wait so you did YouTube videos for a
real or because you went to do two
videos the first youtuber I started
working with was uh Jimmy Tatro he's
really funny and he's like a traditional
actor too okay yeah so I start doing
videos with him so I can build like my
acting reel and then I started trying to
do my own by didn't know much about
editing or filming
yep advantage hidden money yeah oh one
more point you win
okay so who's serving yeah Amanda I'm
quick question what would your fans
really want to know about you right now
if you could answer one question about
me yeah what do they always ask I feel
like a lot of people always ask me if
I'm gonna live YouTube because you know
they get super scared but I always tell
them that I don't say it a lot that I
say like if YouTube disappears something
else will be there and you can be
created there so it's not so Instagram
Twitter like whatever people think as
think a singer I think that we're
youtubers and without youtubers we die
that bring it in I'm like dirty and beat
up
good game her mom oh I'm sweating
already we'll have to celebrate and go
play three I know I'm sweating I'm gross
but I have a prize for you a prize yes
yes so while you wait another question
is what's your ultimate goal like career
goal where do you want to be I actually
will love acting but I'm really focusing
on music so if I can do music I would be
like the happiest guy ever I used to do
like kind of like a rock kind of
situation man then I'm gonna go solo now
and I'm gonna see how it goes
how am i singing come here can get that
is awesome I add you to my Spotify so
here's your prize because yeah your name
is Herman and when I first met you I
thought it was German and German yeah
and I was like oh you and your Hannes
we'll get along so well
we can totally speak in German oh yeah
that's good so here you go there you go
the champion champion wait where's the
crown no problem thank you guys so much
for watching make sure you like
subscribe turn on the notifications and
comment below who you want me to see
plate wait who you want me to who you
want to see me play next one two time
was turning
[Music]